le puy du fou va revivre le puy du fou
vivre à aller le 21 mai sur twitter
philippe de villiers a remercié le
président macron d'avoir intercédé pour
la réouverture rapide du parc à thème de
vendée immédiatement certains ont crié
aux passe droits ou liens d'amitié qui
unit les deux hommes car le puy du fou
est un sujet clivant n'est pas le droit
de dire ça en cause la personnalité de
son créateur de l'ailier j'ai 32 ans je
suis vendéen tressait de métier et
saltimbanques de conviction en 1978 ce
jeune sous préfet va monter un spectacle
de son et lumière au château des épices
ce scénario évoque l'histoire de la
vendée à travers le témoignage que peut
nous apporter le château du pin il faut
le succès est immédiat surtout auprès
des régionaux le spectacle fait la part
belle à la contre-révolution de 1793 la
guerre civile et le massacre d'environ
200000 vendéen une cicatrice vivens pour
certains historiens à quel drame peut-on
comparer le martyre de la rondelle à
tous les génocides contemporain que ce
soit celui des juifs des biafrais des
bengalis des khmers mais très vite ce
spectacle qualifié parfois de
conservateurs on lui reproche de donner
une vision idyllique des rapports entre
paysans et aristocrates de faire la
promotion de la foi chrétienne et de
réduire la révolution française à
l'épisode de la terreur alors 93 c'est
quoi pour nous en négatif c'est la loi
c'est la matrice du totalitarisme qui
fonctionne si revendait pour la première
fois et en positif c'est le geste
héroïque des vendéens qui se battent
pour leur foi pour la liberté
philippe de villiers vous faire de cet
épisode sanglant un acte fondateur de
l'histoire de france
en chaque français il y aurait un
vendéen
les réfractaires au jacobinisme parisien
qu'est-ce qu'on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui décentralisation et les
vendeurs ont été les premiers à
comprendre que paris ne pouvait pas
avoir le monopole n'est ni de l'âge est
né de la rencontre et de la culture
cet esprit de résistance on le
retrouvera dans différents tableaux
scéniques du puy du fou le goulot à
clovis jeanne d'arc verdun toutes les
figures du roman national sont conviés
au puy du fou
qu'est-ce qui ne déclarent voyante c'est
une idée folle caresser le succès est
immense
le puy du fou devient un parc à thème en
1989 et vendra son savoir faire à
d'autres parcs à l'étranger un concept
basé sur la défense de traditions il
s'agit pas de faire en tunisie au canada
à shanghai ce qu'on fait en france et en
vendée s'agit de retrouver chez eux
leurs traditions leurs coutumes leur
identité le puy du fou ouvrira même une
école en 2015 dans victoire il y as
combien sylla avec lever de drapeau
uniforme pour les enfants et une
inauguration façon harry potter
vous accueillir aujourd'hui dans la cour
du château le coeur du pidou des valeurs
qui reflète l'engagement politique de
philippe de villiers de droite
souverainiste dans la lignée des
résistant à l'envahisseur tels que lui
les voies tels qu'ils sont dépeints dans
ses spectacles la gaze